what is up guys I'm going be showing you
a new money-making guide that involves
the new city in the tazar lair I'm not
sure how to pronounce it so I'm not
going to try but anyway the requirements
for this you need your a fire Cape you
don't have to get rid of it but you do
have to show them in order to get
through the gate and you also need some
tokle so I personally don't know the
cheapest way to get tokle but I think
it's selling chaos runes to the Rune
shops in the tazar pits but I'm
personally not sure but I had a bunch of
tokko left over from doing the fight
caves so I went ahead and used this and
what we're going to be doing is buying
uncut SA fires from the new gem store
all right let's get
[Music]
[Applause]
started all right guys so we're here at
the shop in the new city and we'll go
ahead and start our timer so what you're
going to want to do you're going to want
to trade The Gem Shop guy and you're
going to want to buy five of them at a
time and then you're going to go ahead
and hop worlds takes a little bit
and then click here to play and then go
ahead and trade them and buy five
more and hop
worlds and you do this until you have a
full inventory and then once you have a
full inventory as you can see we're in
the new city I think it's more you wreck
and then you run up to the bank up there
to the
North and then you go ahead and Bank
your Sapphires and then you
restart so again to to get into the city
you have to give up you don't have to
give up your fire Cape but you have to
show them your fire Cape to get in and
you also need to have tokal which is
what I have in my inventory and The
Sapphires buy I think originally for 35
tokal and they sell for like
1.1k in the grand exchange okay so once
you unlock your bank if you have a bank
pin just go ahead and put them in there
and then run back down to the South to
The Gem Shop and just continue buying
the uncut Sapphires and I'm going to go
ahead and do this until I run out of
Toco and then show you guys how much I
made and how much time and then do the
math hourly so we can see how much money
we can make from this new moneymaking
method so it turns out it's actually
much better and a lot quicker just to
buy all the gems in the shop instead of
buying five at a time because the total
difference I think it only gets up to
like 43 and it starts at 35 so it's
really not that big of a
difference so I've been doing this for
about 12 minutes and I'm just going to
show you guys how much I have
now and we're going to kind of see how
much money we can make
so I had 20 in here already so we're
just going to take
out however many okay
146 and we're going to see how much
they're
worth so
172k so we'll do 60 divid by the 12
minutes that it's taken
5 * the 17
72k so 860k an hour so we'll keep doing
this and we we'll go ahead and see how
much money we can make if this was done
just by buying them out of the shop
instead of just the five cuz originally
I just bought five at a time and I think
that was a lot slower so I'm going to
continue to do this and I'll show you
guys when I'm done okay so I just
finished I can't buy
anymore I'm just going to spend the rest
of this Tok on whatever I can buy let's
check them
all all right I'm just going to buy
those get rid of it okay I can't buy
anything
else now I will go to the Grand exchange
I will take them all out and I will see
how much money we
made remember that I had 20 of these in
there
before so I'll put back
20 and it took 30 minutes to buy all
these so five
51k so we'll go ahead and times that by
two because it took or sorry
544k so one almost 1.1 mil so you can
make 1 mil an hour doing this method and
it's very easy all you need is toal and
a fire Cape thanks for watching guys and
stay tuned for my next video